foreign
[Music]
thank you once again for inviting me
this afternoon uh seasons greetings and
a happy Christmas to you all and so I
have a prayer as we begin
heavenly father in this season of Advent
as we prepare and approach Christmas
we ask for your guidance for ourselves
and for our world
into the darkness of winter send your
light
we lift the members of this Council to
you and The Business of this meeting
guide them as they meet today give them
inspiration and humility so that all
their intentions and actions might seek
only the services of the communities
they represent and the well-being of all
of those entrusted to their care in the
name of Jesus Christ amen
thank you members if you'd like to sit
down thank you
well thank you very much indeed to all
of you have managed to make it in today
our uh
first item is actually our launching
Officer Phil is going to mention
something about our Declarations of
Interest the changes on the form so
thank you chairman um just to note that
um item two on your agenda today
Declarations of or disclosures of
Interest there's new wording for that
um I think both the liberal Democrat
group and the conservative group have
had sessions with me where I've
explained about the new changes in terms
of declaring interests and the actions
to be taken if you've been really quick
this afternoon about 20 minutes ago I
sent you all an email just to back that
up and in closing a couple of documents
that should help you and also in looking
at your current public register of
interest to make sure it's all accurate
and up-to-date I'm passing some forms of
the um for the public register of
interest to some councilors this
afternoon and please if you do have any
amendments please either let me have
them or or Sam bets thank you chairman
thank you Phil
okay
um David would you like to uh have our
apologies for absence today
thank you chairman um apologies have
been received from councilors Cleve
Fleming Harris
Jefferson Jennings Kendall Kettle
O'Donnell and Rolf thank you thank you
um right item two disclosures of
Interest members do you have any ex
disclosures Council fitter
thank you Chad um
in regards to item 10 I'm employed by
the stratford-on-avon conservative
Association as the office
and campaign manager I responded to the
consultation regarding to a new adjacent
Ward
um so therefore I will leave the meeting
on item 10. thank you thank you
councilman de gallo
7 10 again
the diversity officer for the local
liberal Democrats and the Parliamentary
process prospective parliamentary
candidate so as such on the executive
but both positions are voluntary and
unpaid and I hope I could get
dispensation today thank you thank you
councilor Paulie Hawkins
[Music]
foreign
thank you very much
so just in regard to item 10 I'm
granting a general dispensation to
members other than councilor fitter to
participate and to vote on this item
simply because all councilors have an
interest in this matter and without you
all being there we wouldn't be able to
pass this business so for that reason
it's a dispensation granted to all of
you thank you very much
um
oh councilor o'cock I didn't see you in
the back there
if you're permission if I could remain
seated yes no problem at all thank you
and good luck when it when your
operation does come along
please
um they won't be debated at this meeting
as a Housing Association tenant
um I do have Aid to throw his book
interests in that item
thank you all right
thank you very much indeed our members
uh item three is minutes of the previous
meeting which now is quite a long time
ago in October
um I'm seeking a proposal for those
councilor fitter may I have a second to
please
Council Parry thank you very much indeed
minutes are agreed thank you
right
um
announcement
my very first one and a very pleasurable
one is to make announcements for long
service Rewards for our staff
so the first of three members today
which is really excellent I'm going to
be presented to uh Maggie Lucas with
25-year service
Uh Kevin rolls with 40-year service
neither of him unfortunately are able to
be here today however Martin Cowan with
a mere 25 years is here today would you
like to come up and accept your reward
please Martin
[Applause]
thank you very much
foreign
[Applause]
I would also just like to add about
um apologies for absence Bill Fleming
who was taken into Hospital on Friday uh
not at all well so I'm sure we send our
best wishes to him uh and I will be
sending a card on behalf of all of us to
him very shortly councilor Junior
which is going to say the same
prediction yes I will certainly do that
no problem at all thank you for that uh
right and I understand that um Mr engine
serifin is playing Santa today
so there you go
season of Good Will and all the rest of
it
and he needs a beard
right and I'd like also mention please
if I may uh I'd like to thank all the
staff who uh contributed via the jumper
dress down day and also the quiz which I
have to admit
we did when but there we go that's
another that's another story but uh I'd
like to thank them all for the
contributions to my Charities this year
which as you know are the rnli and also
for dementia centers and I will be
working with our centers on that over
the next few months
so um are we ready the back there
I'd just like to run through some of the
items I've been or the events I've been
going to over the last couple of months
and it's been a busy period a very
interesting one
foreign
next slide please
now that's not a mistake
I was invited by David Wilson homes
to a eat in the dark
day
which is quite quite fascinating it's
there because they support the guide
dogs or the blind uh next slide please
and we were invited to a meal where we
had to eat a meal completely in the dark
next slide please
it was quite an experience and you don't
realize just how how you depend on
others and the gentleman bury at the
back there uh he lost his sight
overnight
it was one of those catastrophic
failures in his optic nerve and he lost
his sight overnight which must be
devastating for someone it took him a
couple of years to get the confidence
and then he had the dog a guide dog and
now he's out and about and supporting
organizations like this which I found
absolutely fascinating so it was a
really interesting day next slide please
uh obviously I went to the the
um Herald's award uh evening which was
really interesting I loved it through
all the enthusiasm with all the
businesses uh who are at startups
especially uh it was an amazing evening
and I thoroughly thoroughly enjoyed that
uh as you can see
next slide please
then I was invited to the theater to see
A Christmas Carol and if you haven't
been go it really really is good amen
Adrian Abington was absolutely stunning
as the Scrooge in there uh thoroughly
enjoyable and a classic Shakespeare
theater production brilliant next slide
please
we've obviously had Armistice Day and
we've had remembrance Sunday and
although Council kettle's not here I'd
like to say thank you to subbing for me
I couldn't be in two places at once uh
that particular one incidentally is the
Royal Navy so I thought the naval Naval
connection there with me
next slide please
and one evening we went to the Ulster
Academy and they put on a play there's
over a hundred of the students there and
it was the world's greatest show and I
can't get over the enthusiasm of all
these these kids going in there and just
giving it giving it them their all and
they were brilliant
and then next slide please
then I went to see Peter Donahoe at the
Trinity Church whose world-class pianist
now not just a brilliant pianist but
also here mentors some of the children
from schools including this young lady
from kez so he spends he's over comes
over for about three days and then he
actually helps them do master classes
learn different skills and I thought
that was an absolutely brilliant
brilliant thing now there is a gap there
I was hoping to put a slide in from the
heart of England Forest planting day we
we had a cracking day out planting trees
and thank you for all who were able to
come that day I think we put in about
230 240 trees and like that a really
good day out thank you next slide please
then if those who've never been if you
have the opportunity please do go to the
side by side uh performance I only see a
few people nodding their heads because
it is a really fantastic performance uh
it's for people with learning
difficulties and they spend most of the
Year rehearsing the actual play and it
gets better and better and better
um I think Council Mills and I went with
the night where I was mayor and you were
chair wasn't it foreign
so again well worthwhile next slide
please
and this is an interesting one I've now
been to two toy services and this is
where uh parishioners of a church donate
toys for needy families and at least it
means that some of the children will
have something to open on Christmas day
otherwise they would be without and
that's a marvelous thing to do and it
does warm the heart a little bit both of
these are now being given to the
workshire Social Services for
distribution to the needy families
thank you next time
and from one extreme to another
I was then interested uh invited I
should say to another
agricultural in uh Enterprise shall we
say it's bringing up in this area in
Tamworth
uh it's called Bruce's Doggy Daycare
Center
next slide please
and it's all about dogs of course well
it would be wouldn't it and yes you do
get upstaged by the dogs there's no toys
about it it's an interesting idea it's
quite well settled down in the South but
moving up into the Midlands and the idea
I think is because of so many people had
pets during covid and now they're back
out at work this is an opportunity for
someone to say well we'll look after
your dogs and give them a great time as
well
so I think that's the last slide isn't
it oh no next slide please
and naturally we went to the Victorian
Market
uh and next slide please
and I can safely say that the mayor and
I were both extremely cold that night
but it was a great evening it was quite
bitterly cold that night
um and I think that's it so that's just
a brief run through uh there's one other
thing which I just want to mention and
that is that over this period as well I
was able to take some students from the
schools the senior schools in Ulster to
the University of Warwick for a day at
the politics Department there and they
had the opportunity to engage in a
lecture and the debate and it was really
quite an interesting time for them and
hopefully we'll be able to do a few more
of those in the not too distant future
right thank you very much indeed that's
all I've got to say
um I would now like to invite the deputy
leader to give us an update because
obviously uh Tony is not available today
thank you chairman I think clearly the
moral is don't work with children and
animals there
um just a few announcements from the
leader around some of his activity over
the last six weeks or so
um he's attended the West Midlands
employers management board he sits on
that board which is the organization
that particularly supports us around
senior recruitment for things like the
chief executive and the section 151
officer the leader also visited the
porter Brook rail Innovation Center at
long master and some of you will be
aware of that it's got the the only
pretty much the only rail Loop in the
country and he's starting to be a hub I
should say for rail Innovation including
the the hydrogen train and that was
quite interesting because uh he was
joined on that meeting by Martin Yardley
who works with the University of Warwick
around developing some of their
commercial activities and Outreach and
arising from that introduction and there
there is the possibility of some
discussions around cooperation between
ports Brook and the university
um in terms of working together on on
engineering and rail Innovation and that
was uh sort of support uh or fill in the
Gap where Birmingham University are no
longer going to be involved in in the
Innovation Center
um the leader also along with myself and
councilor parry and some of our officers
attended the Stratford Herald business
and tourism awards dinner
um the leader gave an uh an award for
one of the categories and it's a theory
he gave an upbeat speech regrettably I
didn't get my phone out in time to
record that for you all but you will
have to take my word for it that it was
upbeat he also
um attended and this is where my heart
begins to sink he was intent invited by
the Coventry and Warwickshire Chamber of
Commerce to attend a briefing on
monetary policy by Hugh pill Chief
Economist at the bank of England and how
we shall all look forward to his report
on that at the next full Council
the Coventry and Warwickshire chamber
also advised him to their annual
business an economic conference uh and
certainly picked up a number of messages
there around the issues that are
affecting local businesses which do
reflect you know issues that affect our
residents as well things like energy
costs and things like that so
um that seems to be you know
particularly the key the key thing for
both residents and businesses in the
district
um he also was one of the West Midlands
leaders who met with the LGA uh that's
one of their I think quarterly briefings
is it I think it believe it's a
quarterly briefing for for all leaders
across West Midlands and lastly has
attended a meeting with the wmca and all
of the non-constituent members and that
was focused on how
wmca and the non-cons can sort of work
more closely and perhaps deepen that
relationship I think you know we're
quite Keen to engage with wmca as much
as we can and to and to and to help
benefit the district and it looks like
there's potentially some more uh work
going on with that and that's really the
the leaders announcements
um I think the final thing just would
like to take the opportunity
um it's coming up to Christmas so on
behalf of the leader the cabinet and
every other single member I'd like to
wish all of our staff a very happy
Christmas and safe and prosperous New
Year and to ensure that we record our
thanks to all of our staff it's been
another challenging year our staff have
again unsurprisingly as we all know they
will step up to the plate delivered for
our residents and have done a first-rate
job throughout the year so I just want
us all to make sure we uh we record our
thanks and wish them all a merry
Christmas and perhaps give them a quick
Round of Applause
[Applause]
thank you very much
um thank you thank you Deputy leader for
them words
um a couple of announcements from me
thank you uh firstly we if you recall we
had a really good debate at the last
council meeting on the state of the
district and at the back of the room uh
Simon purfield kept lots of notes about
additional information that that was
required by councilors that hasn't been
forgotten Simon and the team are working
on that and then the next few days we
should be able to get some further
information circulated to the elected
members secondly I just want to talk
about the sound system so this week we
are appointing our contractors for the
installation of our new sound system
it's a firm called vpav and those
familiar with the sound system at
Warwick District Council will identify
that it's actually the same system that
is working at work at the moment
they're going to be installed in the
system between the 19th of December and
the 13th of January
and that therefore has had the
implications for a number of our
meetings that would have normally been
held in this particular room that the
council chamber that is so so firstly
the climate change panel which is
meeting on the 10th of January that will
continue to meet on the 10th of January
but that will be held in room 137 and
not in the council chamber
the planning committee which is
scheduled for the 21st of December will
be going ahead although it's going to be
held in rooms two three and four and not
the council chamber itself
the planning committee that was
scheduled for the 11th of January will
be moving to the 18th of January
the overview and scrutiny committee that
was scheduled for the 6th of
January will now be held on the 13th but
not in the council chamber that will be
held again in room 137
and then finally the cabinet meeting
that was scheduled for the 9th of
January there was also an extraordinary
cabinet meeting scheduled for the 16th
and therefore all of the business that
was scheduled for the night will be
moved to the 16th of January as well I
should give our contractors a clear run
implementing the new system and then
hopefully the very first meeting that
we'll be using the system will be that
of the uh the cabinet on the 16th of
January thank you chairman thank you
um also members you're possibly aware
that uh Mr Dolby has asked for us to
wait behind after this meeting
um for an update on the
um sort of the book ID yeah go for ID
thank you
also I'm putting on a few Refreshments
at the end as well so I thought it might
be an opportunity to well then the
meeting go and have some refreshments
come back down and then Mr Dolby can do
his his bit at the at the appropriate
time so I hope you'll join me uh for a
few refreshments as it is Christmas
thank you very much right so moving on
to item four five public participation
none
uh item six
uh it's the neighbor the town within
Arden a neighborhood development plan
and I would like to invite councilor
Pemberton Deputy leader to introduce
this report
thank you chairman um
members uh Tamworth and Arden held its
referendum on the 24th of November this
year where the community endorsed their
neighborhood development plan with a an
87.1 yes vote
um and at the general the the ballot
generated a turnout of 15.89 of eligible
voters
um first of all just want to record the
thank my thanks to the members of the
Tamworth in our neighborhood development
plan group for all of their hard work uh
we all know how how much work is
involved in bringing ndps to fruition
and would also like to thank officers
from the planning policy team for their
work in supporting the neighborhood
group
um I can see uh councilor Dixon uh
wishes to
um speak so before we get to the
recommendation I'll I'll defer to
councilor Dixon cows make some
um
because I was indeed going to give uh
but I will actually be slightly more
specific uh apart from Parish Council
the the work that was really done in
respect to this NDP we're done by
councilor Mike Saunders and a Gentleman
Paul Jonathan Ashcroft
um so uh my thanks particularly to those
two to the parish council and indeed I
Echo your thanks to the policy team who
have provided help and assistance
throughout the process which has been an
incredible eight years thank you very
much indeed
thank you so the recommendation to
cancel is that the Tamworth in Arden
neighborhood development plan uh
appendix one to the portfolio decision
of the 29th of November is adopted with
immediate effect with the consequence
that it becomes part of the development
plan stratford-upon-avin districts and
just looking for a proposer in a second
well I take it you've moved the
recommendation
I'm looking for a second councilor Dixon
thank you all members uh are you in
favor agreed thank you
next item item seven the community
governance review Great Wall foot and
little Walford I invite the Council of
Pemberton to introduce this report
please thank you I'm introducing half
the councilor Capital here thank you
thank you chair I'm introducing this
matter on behalf of councilor Kettle who
who can't be with us and this relates to
the community governance review to
undertaken at the request of great
Wilford uh and little Wolford great
Wilford Parish Council and little
Wolford Parish meeting uh with a request
that they merge to form a joint
Parish Council I can see councilor Wally
hoggins may wish to speak before we get
to the recommendation so I'll defer to
councilor Wally hoggins
thank you the residents of great Wilford
and little Wilford have been discussing
this for a number of years really and
I'm pleased to say that they have come
together in wanting this to now happen
and I'm also pleased to say that how
that that we have had responses from the
Buddhism it means there has been some
some engagement as well which has been
fantastic so I wholeheartedly hope that
this does go ahead
um for the sake of all the all of the
residents in in both in both in both
parishes really so I I commend this to
this Council thank you Council
thank you I I now move the
recommendations on page 35 of your
papers the great wallford Parish Council
and little Walford Parish meeting be
merged and be named The walford's Joint
Parish Council and that the head of Law
and governance be authorized to execute
the reorganization order made under the
local government and public involvement
in health act 2007. I seek a second for
that
down to Oregon audience thank you very
much agree agreed thank you
item eight
is an update to the Constitution
committee procedure rules planning
committee
right Council Pemberton on the on behalf
of councilor Jefferson
thank you very much Tim and yes I
realize this is becoming tedious but
there we are following on from changes
to
um the operation of planning committee
um this paper brings forward an update
to the Constitution as it relates to
planning committees uh during uh which
changed their method of operation during
the Kobe pandemic it's Amen it's
proposed to amend the procedure rules to
revert back to the previous duration
time of a meeting to bring the planning
committee in line with other Committees
of the council the recommendation is
that the change to the council's
Constitution which is detailed in
appendix one to the report be approved
seeking a seconder
Council Richards thank you very much
um right in that case then thank you
very much oh sorry Council
because I
was taken ill after an extended meeting
and I I support this proposal because
not only does it align it with all the
other committees but it places an option
before the committee to do something
sensible and I certainly I I know our
chairman is very good at doing that and
I commend him for that
um so and I think it's used for I
actually uh I'm a bit of numerologist I
did not actually look at the statistics
as how long to take and I think we
shouldn't be in a position where we do
have to rush applications I think the
challenge that we face on the planet
which is when we we get too many and
we're we're we we try to get stuff uh
through and again I do recommend the
chairman for helping us to make sure we
don't a rough things that we do have a
full debate the one thing I would ask is
to is to consider and I um I have had a
conversation with the head of
development management where that we
couldn't look at um
the relatively short notice his members
get when something is being referred to
committee whether we can filter some of
these things out and I thought I'm not
going to try and present a an example of
that but if we've got too many on on a
particular committee that is where we
Face a problem with overrunning so I
think perhaps a bit more partnership
working thinking about how these things
come forward to committees worth
thinking about but I I'm very happy with
the um with the proposity for us thank
you very much chairman thank you thank
you Council Rock and well noted and
thank you for that
um so I now have a proposer and I have a
second day with councilor Richards uh
all members in agreement
thank you
right moving on to item nine minute 388
Canada meetings and I invite uh Council
fitter
to introduce this item thank you
he has looked at meetings for the next
two years so we can suggest
meetings for the calendar for 2023-24
but then also a provisional set of
meeting dates for 20 24 25 to help
officers and the council move forward
with planning so please and I proposed
these calendar meetings please
uh yes Council unit
with the current habit of making sure
that a voltage is taken at the beginning
of the any particular committee as to
what time of day that committee will
meet because I I think it's becoming
clearer and clearer that with so many
counselors working that many more
Council meetings in the future might
very well
um counselors might very well appreciate
afternoon and evening meetings rather
than morning meetings but that will be
up to each individual committee that
will continue our assume yes
thank you very much
um I need a second for that
cancer unit are you happy to second that
thank you very much indeed all members
uh in agreed thank you
right the next item then is minute item
10.
minute 389 review of polling districts
and polling places and I'd like to
introduce ask Council Wally hoggins to
introduce this item
committee did a look at the review of
polling districts and polling places
there was a long and detailed discussion
that went on about this and there's
ample time given for members of that
committee
um to to voice opinions on the matter
however it was resolved that we
recommended that the polling districts
and polling places review are set out in
the appendix once the Agenda Report to
include the updates at South and
Southward and king's court and Ulster
Heath as detailed uh be be approved I've
also prior to this meeting spoken to our
Democratic services manager about
um that the fact that ships and South
currently has three polling districts
listed in the report I believe that has
now been narrowed down to two but that
is still still
I'm satisfied that both of the both
venues are suitable for for what for
what is required so we're looking at
Stratford shipston North and the
shipston South
um polling venue thank you
okay
look I'm looking now for a second of a
council Pemberton
are all members agreed
hold on
apologize I didn't see your hand okay
but thank you chairman I've done it
twice now
um you thought I was second in it when I
was in fact wanted to make it just
waving action
I'm delighted to wave at you chairman
um
yes I just want you to add there's a
there's a couple of paragraphs which
quite correctly reports the proceedings
of the committee where I was concerned
about uh some smaller communities within
my ward being inconvenienced by the
changes
um I am fully uh seized of the desire
and the need to accept the Democratic
verdict of the committee be an authority
debate about it I would note that those
communities are going to be considerably
inconvenienced by something that I think
is
I I personally think he's not sensible I
think they're being made to to drive an
excessive rural distance uh and for
something that's a fairly academic
change however I do accepted the uh the
falling plate we had uh so it's
unfortunate for those smaller number of
residents but I just wanted to make that
point chairman thank you thank you
um councilor Roy Hawkins
just to say that at that meeting uh we
were all entirely sympathetic with
regard to the to the situation of those
those residents as well thank you thank
you I'm sure it's it's a very difficult
one for officers to sort that out I I
wouldn't want to do it myself so I do
appreciate it members are we all agreed
on this
okay thank you
right
[Music]
abstention be noted please oh yes it's
certainly good I didn't realize I must
look at you more often Castle Rock it's
no good
abstention thank you okay item 11 is
minute 410 adoption of the
infrastructure funding statement and
councilor Pemberton on behalf of council
Jefferson would you like to introduce
this report please oh sorry council do
that
I don't know whether you want to I can
go after his Yeah Yeah by all means
thank you chairman
um
thank you chairman members will be aware
that um as part of the community
infrastructure Levy regime we are
required to
publish and infrastructure funding
statements and we're required to submit
on an annual basis retrospectively by
December uh our annual statements and
um that requires us to adopt the ifs for
2122 and this is in that respect a sort
of retrospective piece of work and talks
about the funding statement which is our
approach rather than specific projects
there was some discussion at cabinet
um where some members
brought forward
concerns about how we might address
where projects might potentially stall
or appear to be stalled or maybe taking
longer to bring to fruition I think the
first thing to remember is that we're in
essence
we receive bids assess bids and the
primary duty is with those who submit
bids for sale funding to drive those
projects forward there was some
discussion and some requests West about
a formalized review and proactive sort
of pushing of schemes
I certainly take the view that there
isn't a need for a formalized review
particularly with sort of current
budgetary constraints I would struggle
to justify the you know a specific
officer for that
having said that just to give as I tried
to a cabinet to give members of The
Wider Council Assurance we do have a
weather eye on the projects and how they
are progressing and there have already
been a number of occasions where
officers have been proactive in having
discussions to bring projects forward a
project particularly involving the
environment agency where there was some
discussion about
the appropriateness of bringing certain
parts of the project forward in a given
time scale so I'm comfortable that we
can leave to senior officers the
identification of any quote projects
that are stalling and there's a
mechanism thereby to actually bring
those forward rather than to introduce
something on a more formalized basis and
with that I'm looking for us to adopt
the infrastructure funding statement and
we'll seek a second after that but I do
see that counselor Junior mayor yeah I
raised quite a lot of questions and I
was not the only one at
foreign
about the size of the section 106 and
sell payments that are in the council's
bank account and and some not being
spent
um within a reasonable amount of time uh
particularly uh one one in Ulster which
is a flood risk management issue which
um has not been spent that's a still one
and that that it does require
negotiation with environment agency and
the environment agency needs to find
more funds uh but the other issue that
was raised was about
um when section 106 is brought in and
seal is brought in it is meant for a
reasonably meant for uh addressing the
infrastructure needs of the community
from which the develop in which the
development has occurred and one thing
that has disturb me is how frequently
that money is not spent in the in the
development in the
um Community for which in which it which
is taking that development and I really
wanted to have a look at that looked at
um I wanted to have a look at how long
those sums of money are being held by
the council and I wanted to have a look
at
um how a partnership and
hand-holding operation can occur from
officers to these outside organizations
to make sure that projects are properly
managed and occur so one thing that
might be useful would be that overview
uncrutiny could have a look long term at
the the whole section 106 sill
infrastructure and financial before the
one next one has to be in place because
I am I'm not happy with the length of
time that some of these projects
projects are taking and I'm not happy
that the council is therefore having
sums of money held with it that should
be
um
usefully used for infrastructure within
communities
thank you I'm noted and I think it was a
good discussion on that at osc as well I
think Council
declarations about process on how the
seal money is allocated to the eligible
projects which I've made the list
son
[Music]
thank you yes
um
I'm I do think we need to find some
better way of measuring some of these
project progress against key benchmarks
I won't mention that what I've got in
mind because members will probably be
fed up with me mentioning the same one
but in February 2021
we were informed that a particular
project was ready to go and it was
allocated 850 000 pounds now 850 000
pounds of taxpayers money right at the
moment is a lot of money we need to be
really careful and I think
I'm aware that offices are under a great
deal of pressure but I think unless we
have some better way of measuring
outputs from these grants these this
this still funding
um we're actually not using that money
wisely so I take House of pemberton's
point that we need to be careful about
how we allocate resources but I think in
this instance perhaps additional sources
resources need to be allocated to ensure
that we're getting best value from those
sums invested thank you chair thanks
before you're standing Council Wally
Hawkins please
yeah I'm referring to the cabinet papers
from the 28th of November I'm looking at
table 4C money received this final
Studio that is to be transferred to
external bodies and I'm just taking the
Assurance from the front of this Council
chamber really because one of the
biggest recipients of this money is the
NHS taking in 921
000 pounds do we you know
throughout all of this is that actually
drawn down or are we just sort of saying
there you go do with it do with it as
you as you wish because uh particularly
residents in my area are slightly
concerned about health care provision at
the moment I'm making do we know where
that money is going do they come back to
us to tell us where it's get what that
money is being spent on the the issue
that I've got here is that you know
again under table 4C I'm sorry to go on
about it you know we're already making
additional payments the police of 22 000
pounds plus and to watch the County
Council of another sum of money we
already collect money
um for for them via the council tax
system so what I'm seeking is for our
residents is what exactly do we find out
what exactly this money has been
spending on or do they just say thanks
very much we'll just add it to the abyss
pot does that make sense I said Abyss
hot thank you thank you
all right thank you very much chairman
thank you for your observations and
contributions I I think firstly I would
just say
we have in front of us an infrastructure
funding statement and a number of the
issues that you've all raised
are actually aside from the the ifs so
in terms of the decision that's in front
of us
um we do have to publish an ifs
um in terms of how we spend and how we
evaluate projects we as a council have
agreed a still spending protocol so
we've all signed up to that and our
officers follow that protocol and
they're clearly if overview scrutiny
felt that they wanted to revisit that
that is entirely a matter for
overviewing security but just to remind
members that our officers are following
a still spending protocol that this
Council and members of this Council have
approved
um I'm quite comfortable that you can
always revisit things and seek
Improvement but just so we understand
that that's that in answer to your
question councilor together that's the
start point is the spending protocol and
the prioritizations there thereof
um
I'm still not minded that
um specific resource be directed to the
management and progress of silk projects
frankly we've then got to decide what
else we're not going to do and I'm not
sure that we should be thinking in terms
of additional resource to hold the
environment agency's hand the big enough
and old enough to hold their own hand
and I think we should be pushing them
and I think we can and I have confidence
in our officers to push projects
councilor junid I think you the Ulster
project came up and I I think I I think
I made a a a suggestion that if you
touch base with the head of uh
development and policy to look at that
particular project and I think across
all members if you ever saw projects in
your award that you think is not
progressing you're the in lots of ways
you're the eyes and ears of this
organization bring that to us and that's
as good a way of because you'll be
engaging with some of the community
groups that are involved in some of
these seal projects and if there's some
barrier then let's talk about that and I
think that that is a good enough system
I I don't think we need a Rolls-Royce
when a mini will do the job so I'm I'm
happy with that undoubtedly you may wish
to you know think otherwise but that's
where I think we should remain at the
moment and as far as the NHS is
concerned under section 106 uh there's a
formula basis uh and so in that respect
um that drives what is uh paid under
section 106 and the health or education
or whatever it might be have to
demonstrate that the the spend that they
want to uh use or the the purpose which
I want to use this the section 106
funding
um is in line with something arising out
of that particular development and that
gets built into the section 106
agreement
I think with particularly health and
education there are challenges where
there is some at least anecdotal
evidence that money on money's not
necessarily been spent where the
development takes place and the
timeliness of that spend can be called
into question
um there's a there's a live issue with
section 106 spend
um
where actually it would appear the NHS
can't make up their mind what the what
this what they want to do
for a particular community and we
potentially face The Madness of sending
money back to a developer well that's
not happening as far as anybody in this
room is concerned so we're being
proactive in that instance to say come
on guys get yourself sorted you've got
money here to create Health Care
Facilities get on with it what have we
got to do do we have to change the s106
agreement to make it easier for you uh
because we're just we're just not
sending money back so I think there's a
number of different issues that have all
come out of that which is useful for
debate I would urge members that we need
to
confirm the ifs but clearly if uh you
know the members of overview and
scrutiny want to review that's
absolutely within their gift
um so I would hope that members can now
hopefully that's given some uh detail
for you uh adopt the ifs statement thank
you thank you and I think it's a it's a
good discussion on this one I think that
we do probably need to bring this back
to osc
um and we can then analyze that because
I think this but but it comes to um
as I said Pemberton said is absolutely
right we are here today to uh to
recommend to adopt the ifs and can I
have members agreement on that
thank you very much indeed members
valid and good discussion thank you
all right item 12
um minute X the proposed bylaw for the
Bancroft Gardens Tramway and Recreation
ground uh Council Mills
yes uh thank you Mr chairman
um
you have got a paper in front of you for
this I'm assuming you've all had an
opportunity to read it
thanks Mr chairman thank you
um at the meeting of the regulatory
committee on the 9th of December
um consideration was given to the
approval of the proposed bylaw for the
bank of gardens the Tramway and the
recreation ground
at its meeting held on the 24th of June
2022 the committee resolved to approve
the proposed bylaw subject to 28 days
from publication to allow for any
written representation from the General
Public
following the discussion it was
recommended to the council that the
making of the bylaw without modification
for the Bancroft Gardens the Tramway and
the recreation ground be approved
Kingston thank you cousin house I'm
looking for a secondary on that
counselor
um shenton thank you very much indeed
apologies are there any members who wish
to speak on this
no in that case may I have your
agreement members thank you
I think Macy have got off questions
there didn't you well done
[Music]
right item 13 our counselor questions
counselor questions so
um if I can just run from through them
please I noticed two um councilors not
here to today I've sent their apologies
the first question is councilor junett
do you have a supplementary question
uh yes I do
um because
um since the uh question was put
together we had the audience standards
um this morning and I was able to ask a
couple of questions there
um I wonder whether the leader could
raise certain concerns uh with the
government
um about the change I note that the
local government Association Lee chair
councilor Jamison who is a Tory
counselor has asked for the measures to
be delayed because of a risk of access
to the vote
um and that one of the concerns he's
raised is that this does not respect a
long-standing principle that changes
such as this should not be imposed
within six months of a set of Elections
and I know also note that the chief
executive of the association of
electoral administrations is
administrators has also raised concern
about the training of staff
given that um also a number of councilor
leaders quite prominent Council leaders
have written to Michael Gove asking for
a delay as in their belief they any
legal challenge could undermine public
confidence in democracy
um could you please assure me that you
will make due representation along these
lines to Michael Gove or to the LGA
about the time the shortage of time the
pressure it's putting on the council and
also the time available for information
to be put to members of the public and
also the training of Staff it is a major
change and I think it requires proper
due consideration which is not being
done at this moment
thank you councilor General I think that
uh a number of us share your concerns
about the uh the speed at which uh these
uh measures have been brought in
um you have the advantage from my
perspective of you were at that meeting
this morning so I'm probably in the
position where I'd I'd be Keen I'm sorry
[Music]
no
um I've just been told that in fact the
leader may already have written around
that um I certainly know that the leader
wrote on a number of issues to Michael
Gove particularly around planning fees
and it may have been within that so but
equally if you're asking for any further
representation it probably would be
useful if I can if when the leader is
back
take some sanding from the chair of of
the committee just to understand what
the will of the committee is as well but
I take that on board because obviously
uh I didn't have the benefit of being at
that meeting this morning uh and we'll
double check whether the most recent
letter from the leader to Mr go pick
that issue up as well
we'll get there in some way shape or
form thank you Council Junior do you
have a second supplementary on your
second question
adjusted on the um the wording of the
and the question the answer to my
question at the last paragraph it says
the in addition the planning officer
will consult with the environment agency
in certain specified circumstances
dependent on the level of flood risk
could I be uh further updated on what
those sit and specified circumstances
are
um and also to point out that my
question was not only about flood risk
it's about surface drainage and also
that the impact that has on any
particular development
Council shenton
thank you and and thank you councilor
Julie um in in respect to your first
question
um
the environment agency are always
consulted on anything that falls in
floodless two and three which is what
that last paragraph refers to it it
doesn't matter whether it's a big
development or a small one and if it
falls in there
um as far as specific uh as far as your
second question goes I think I'd
probably be safer if I say I will come
back to you okay thank you
thank you question three councilor
Alcock do you have a supplementary
but the answer for that can
um that could be advertised
further because there's an awful lot of
residents who are not aware
and we need to make sure that people
know they can come to this Council
offices between nine and five money to
buy a day for assistance if needed
because welcome
we've been open here as much or more
than any other District Council in the
country as soon as covid restrictions
were lifted sufficiently for us to be
open we were and we've we've been open
from memory from normal o'clock in the
morning till two we're now open full
time so that is on the website
I think it's on Facebook as well I'm
just looking at the person who can tell
me it definitely is because I've looked
at all these so it is advertised widely
if there are any other suggestions as to
how to advertise it plus of course it
goes in any of the paperwork that goes
out from here we've done our absolute
best without
overspending and putting a leaflet to
everybody everybody's door to say that
we are open
and it is used effectively
thank you
Council Jenny franchally do you have a
supplementary question
um answer
um I do have some nuanced questions
within that which I'm not actually going
to raise now but would like to erase
raise outside this office sorry
both of you yes there is considerable
concern from residents about the opening
of airbnbs and how they're run and how
they're monitored so I'd like to talk
about that
yeah
thank you question six counselor Ian
practically do you have a supplementary
question
it's a bit tight here chair but thank
you uh being both a regular cyclist and
a motorist along the Birmingham Road it
is the middle section which is much more
in need of urgent affairs
so it is disappointing that it is
planned to be the last stage rather than
the next stage
and I would hope that we could do
something about that such that the last
stage is done next and not last thank
you
I think perhaps if cancer would like to
uh liaise with the head of develop
development and policy then uh a
potential discussion could be arranged
with Warwickshire County Council
highways about how they're scheduled in
the project that's probably your best
bet
councilman Jenny franchi do you have a
supplementary on question seven
thank you thank you very much councilor
Curtis question eight do you have a
supplemental question and just a comment
if I if I might first of all thank you
very much for to council Harvey for such
a very quickly any questions not
comments
could the counselor confirm
that in fact the deficit for on pension
one for 20 21 22 is now lower in fact
than it was in 2019 2020 which was 40
million
thank you chair Council Harvey
[Music]
councilor Curtis yes
thank you
all right question do you have a
supplementary
[Music]
hey councilman Could you
um could you confirm with these litter
picks have actually happened with the um
with the undertaking that was part of
the application for the planning and if
they haven't when will they start to
happen please
foreign
[Music]
the schedule is quite clear that 30 days
there should be 30 litter picks and they
should be recorded and I'm sure you know
that that's in schedule two of the uh
the agreement
um I don't if I know that you wanted to
know that I would have come armed with
that today so I'll have to go away and
come back to you without the the short
answer is I don't know because you
didn't ask for that but I'm quite happy
to come back to you thank you thank you
and finally question 11 councilor 30
Geller do you have a supplementary
question
okay so regarding the district council
building control team
um what's the procedure for owners or
developers to revert back to the local
Authority do we add that on our website
or could you signpost me to how they go
back to the local Authority on building
regulations issues can I ask a question
back for clarification yeah
um do you mean if an independent
building control has been used in the
first place yes so they revert
well it says here the district council
building control team is unable to take
enforcement action against the developer
unless it is reverted to the local
Authority instigated by the owner
developer so how do how do we do that
what's the process
[Music]
you started something now councilor
please bear in mind I don't do building
control
specifically
[Music]
um
I can be some positive Europe some other
time but you know we we would like to
know please yeah a reversion notice is a
procedure sort of set out in the
approved inspection regulations that my
understanding is that has to be invoked
by the developer themselves if the
relationship between them and their
building control provider breaks down I
don't think it would be posthumously
applied by a homeowner saying that they
wanted that
um building control sort of administered
by the local Authority but I'm happy to
talk through any detail with you outside
of the meter Canterbury together it's
probably the easiest way
thank you thanks for all the questions
um questions to the leader well
obviously the deputy leader
um so we have uh two questions maximum
per member three minutes total three
councilor and only matters of the
responsibility of this Council right
Council put together first then Council
then Council
thank you chair and so the liberal
Democrat MP Desi Cooper is sponsoring a
new bill the planning application fees
Bill if passed the bill will allow local
planning authorities to set their own
planning application fees with the aim
of ensuring that the cost of determining
planning applications is fully funded by
such charges would the deputy leader
agree that this would be beneficial to
our Council and if so would he make or
the leader make representations to
around to local MPS to support this
Cooper's bill
thank you Perth councilor pertigella um
way ahead of you we all know that
planning fees don't cover the cost of
the service and the leader did indeed
write to Michael Gove some weeks ago
requesting that planning fees be
reviewed to ensure that we can cover the
cost and I am aware having seen a copy
of a more wide-ranging response from uh
Mr Gove around planning matters
generally that there is going to be
indeed a review of planning fees
undertaken by hm government to ensure
that planning fees do fully reflect the
costs that we incur because I think they
barely cover as I under as I recall
perhaps the
section one five officer I think it was
barely 50 percent
something like that so yeah we've
already made those representations
thank you uh councilor uh Adam
I was approached by Resident who was
intrigued about the best way to recycle
certain Plastics the app that we've got
that I understand has been well received
by residents uh and I particularly I
actually quite like it find it useful
myself but I've noticed that on the
recycling aspect it doesn't necessarily
give you the uh the naturally recognized
triangle number
associated with each type of plastic
that might be semantics to some but
other people find it quite useful so I
know I've in some cases built the wrong
type of plastic in the in the blue bin
because it's got a recycling triangle on
it all beer that it isn't always
appropriate is it something that we
could consider adding to the app and
online uh portal essentially for just a
bit of added Clarity uh which types of
plastic can be recycled as I said
they're already kind of labeled this
type of plastic can we just add the
triangle uh I think that would be very
useful for residents thank you
um I'm certainly no experts on the on
the signage and I doubt the leader is
either however I think if uh the
portfolio holder isn't here but I will
ensure that the head of service
um takes that on board I don't know what
the answer is in terms of what we can or
can't do but I'll ask the head of
service to liaise with you and let's get
an understanding of what could actually
be done because if we can make the
system work even better that's great for
our residents and if we can improve
recycling rates again if that's what
everybody wants thank you
thank you um no council again did you
handle I can't remember okay Council
Fielding
hey yeah
um I had a question prepared for the
leader but knowing his uh regards for um
uh new inventions in the local press
there's been a reports that Rolls-Royce
are looking for a suitable site for one
of their SMR small modular reactors in
the West Midlands with Warwick
University having facilities at
worldsborne and the need for job
creation in the district has the leader
been in discussions with Rolls-Royce or
Warwick University to find a suitable
site
[Music]
thank you not that I'm aware of
Council Bromwich
as we all know
we've had issues service issues raised
about mold issues and that with housing
associations in recent times I've
actually had to deal with one which has
obviously been completed today on this
does the deputy leader agree with me
that sometimes being very forced with a
Housing Association and giving them very
tight deadlines to achieve desirable
results and as counselors we should
always make sure when we put these
complaints in that we are get a contact
name who we can deal with and keep
liaison with and that this could
actually be sought in very reasonable
time and as we the councils should take
a responsibility to represent our
residents
in issues of substandard Housing and be
prepared to go round to that house to
ensure that everything is done and the
resident has suitable accommodation I
actually I see that on item 16 that is
actually part of the part of that as
well
it's quite relevant and following our
osc meeting I too had a direct link with
Corbett over a particular property and
it did work very quickly so it does help
yeah I do appreciate that Council
Pemberton thank you I I think
um I mean we've all seen recently
um a terrible story of a family
absolutely and utterly let down
um resulting in in the tragic death of a
young child
um and that's just not acceptable in
this country it's not acceptable
anywhere but it's not acceptable here
um I would absolutely and wholeheartedly
endorse what you say around holding the
Housing Association and any other
landlord for that matter I holding their
feet to the fire if you rent a property
out you rent a property out in good
order and you have a duty as a landlord
to make sure it is in good order and as
members it is absolutely our job and I
firmly believe that deadlines Drive
behavior and
difficult as it may be for some of you
to to to believe I sometimes can be
forceful in bringing things and trying
to get to a conclusion so I would
wholeheartedly support any member who
wants to bat for their residence and and
certainly if any of any landlord or
Housing Association in this District
acted in the way that appears to have
been the case elsewhere in the country
it's unacceptable so yeah I don't think
you'll find any anybody challenging that
and I'm sure that our officers will
support you and any other member in in
such Endeavors in the future
thank you Council unit
just following up on on that subject
actually
um because a letter was sent to all
local Authority Chief Executives and
Council leaders uh on the 19th of
November asking that Council set out how
they are prior prioritizing enforcement
of housing standards in the authority
across all tenures including what plans
have been made to ensure adequate
enforcement capacity to drive up
standards in that sector an initial
response was expected by the end of
November could we have sent a copy of
that initial response and what the
council Leader's response was to that
initial letter and could we be kept up
to date on the other responses that are
expected to be sent to Michael Gove in
the near future
that's one question I also have a second
question so uh the response has gone off
and a copy will be made available to all
members
um in terms of uh where we go next this
this thing's got some time to run and I
I actually expect that
um given what's happened
government will ultimately be a lot more
directive about this stuff uh and we
will ensure that you know whatever
changes arise out of this that we uh we
ensure we deliver upon those
um as I said in relation to councilor
brummage it's just not acceptable
um so I think all of us want to ensure
that we do as much as we can as an
authority
um to ensure that the quality of rented
accommodation for our residents
meets the standards that can be
reasonably expected in the 21st century
did you want to do your second question
now Council Junior it would be yeah it
would be useful
um because we
um understand that the budget available
for the discretionary housing benefit
had been exhausted by the end of
November uh with no funding available
for new applications until March 2023.
could you uh show me our Deputy leader
that that is being considered by the
cabinet
um how to fill the Gap until March 2023
when the new government grant will come
in and can you also assure me that
you'll make representations to
government because as I understand it
the discretionary housing benefit has
been decreasing year on year for the
last three years
thank you councilor Junaid
um I think what we'll I'll do then is
take that away uh to members of cabinet
housing portfolio Holder will be far
more across that and I'm sure that we
can help and and provide members with an
update as to where we think we're going
to go uh around any funding shortfall
and around how we ensure that we we can
get uh the best deal for our residents
um so if you would bear with me
councilor Jun Ed
um then we'll take we'll take that away
and uh we'll share that once we've uh
had the chance to sort of discuss that
through the portfolio holder and the
finance portfolio order as well
Council Perry
thank you chairman um could I ask the
deputy leader or Varley Health portfolio
whether they can advise the situation
with regard to Cancer Care appointments
within this um within the South
Warwickshire
um District Health Authority because
there's been seems to be some
misrepresentation going around on
Facebook and other social media sites at
this in fact I think there's something
on today
um regarding the the fact that people
are not getting appointments can I just
advise that a very close family member
of mine
um since going to a GP had an MRI
appointment within two weeks following
that has had a Hospital appointment
confirmed within two weeks I'm just
concerned that
um if this is if if we I think I do
believe we're very fortunate in this
area to have exceptionally good
Healthcare and I would hate our
residents particularly at this time of
year with the pressures on GP following
strap a to the uh fearful that they
won't get uh seen fast tracked for
cancer appointments thank you
I think In fairness that is NHS more
than District Council however
um
I mean I think
um with with forbearance given that if
that if and I'm not I'll be honest I'm
not across uh this this story in that
sense I'm aware that there's been some
things but I think if with forbearance
if the portfolio holder can give any
update I think on the basis that if it
can give some reassurance to Residents
uh if council is happy with that I'm I'm
happy to hear a a short update from the
portfolio holder
thank you
I'm always perturbed when
it looks like there is some saber
rattling going on about Cancer Care
and when it is something that will worry
people
more than is absolutely necessary having
had cancer myself I know that I wouldn't
have been very happy if I'd seen a
Facebook thing that said
um I wasn't going to get looked after
properly one of my colleagues councilor
shenton has just told me about his wife
and her Cancer Care and the fact that
it's you know been on the two weeks 60
days
Etc I mean well these are these examples
within Warwick like within the within
Swift
and Swift has always had and I can speak
to this as a member of the board of
Swift
that
because I'm a district council as well
on the board
um
that they retained more beds and they've
obtained more throughput than we have in
a lot of places in this country and so I
think it's doing a bit of a disservice
to our residents to suggest
that it is anything it it is not working
because my understanding is that it is
thank you very much Council
for Jack I apologize you should have
been next but
[Music]
again
appears to be a changing um a change in
orbit policy
um so over the last seven years if a
resident
becomes disabled
um whether it's
um uh it they develop a disability or it
happens suddenly uh they they usually
helped to stay in their home with
um with changes to their property and
orbit generally in my experience have
been quite accommodating with that
recently I've had several residents
who've had issues
with actually first Port Accords to try
and move them out of their property
rather than make these alterations and
they're usually because of cost this is
very new to me as a counselor it's come
to my attention fairly recently and I
think we need to be asking all that
what is actually happening and have they
changed their policy regarding this
thank you very much
um this actually Taps into my day job in
some respects and best practice is not
to move people out of their home if they
if they've suddenly acquired a
disability because home is where all of
their support structures are and their
neighbors and their friends so I am
quite Disturbed that I made that if
there is some substance to this and have
no reason to disbelieve what you've said
that is not the way that a responsible
landlord should operate and particularly
a Housing Association the first Port of
course should be to maintain that person
in their current home if it is suitable
and I think the devil is in the detail
for all of these things what I would
suggest Council for check is that you're
you're indicating that there is some
Gathering evidence of a change of
approach
um if you wouldn't mind taking a lead on
this with the portfolio holder to to
discuss can I also ask that if any other
member around chamber has had similar
experiences because they perhaps feed
into counselor for checkso there's sort
of one conduit and then we can get one
set of questions one set of
circumstances and then we can engage
with the Housing Association to
understand
what's going on and why it's going on
um and to where appropriate remind them
of how they should act and to encourage
them to act properly so if if you are
comfortable with acting as a sort of a
spokesperson for the for the floor
counselor for check then we can take
that forward I just think that would be
quite useful to so it's all
uh fed through so we've got one line of
communication and I think that was
something undoubtedly the portfolio
Holder will want to take up uh fairly
quickly and I also assure you that as I
say I have a I have a day job interest
in that in the in the issues facing
those with disabilities of all sorts and
I'll take an interest uh in that as well
uh because that's just doesn't on the
face of it seem right
thank you
um Council Bromwich
[Music]
action energy grants for those who
qualify
hopefully councils have been promoted
this well within their communities
but I have come across a little bit of
an issue with this and this in
particular relates to
more vulnerable people who may not be on
social media so I'm not so aware of this
grant that they can get to help with
their gas and electric bill costs is
there any way we can raise the awareness
I know myself I put it through social
media I've done a lot of verbal work
I've actually been around a fair few
people's houses helping them fill in
forms and that's the program it's
particularly the elderly and more
vulnerable who don't tend to have so
much access to the technology or notice
it so much but my concern is that we may
not be giving everybody the opportunity
where they can do and obviously as
counselors we can't walk around and
knock every door and say
just checking here eligible so could we
try and find a solution to heighten the
awareness even more because I can tell
you now from the experience I've had so
far that it's an excellent scheme it's
gone excellent turnaround time and it's
benefiting people
substantially especially in the cold
weather climate thank you Council
Bromwich uh I I saw uh the portfolio
holder
um nodding and would have seen
it would seem that there are perhaps
things that we can do and again perhaps
if you want to just liaise direct with
the portfolio holder I'm sure we'll look
at what other methods we can use to try
and get the message out more broadly
like last question Council Petty Ellen
sadly
ayad also
um incidents in my ward with tenants
having mold dump cold ohms boilers not
working
um you know gaps between Windows and
frame so what enforcement Powers we have
or these local authorities under the
Housing Act 2004 and I would like to
know how many times have we used this
Council as use these Powers against
housing associations who fail our
residents
thank you councilor together
unsurprisingly I can't tell you how
often we've uh just at this point we'll
take it away we'll provide the answer
copy that to members as well I think
picking up
um you've got some specifics there so
you know perhaps again through uh
through to the portfolio holder through
uh councilor forward check let's let's
get an understanding I mean clearly if
you have a particular
if you have a particularly urgent case
can you uh liaise with officers
immediately
um it's good to get portfolio holders or
cabinet members involved but if you've
got something where something needs to
be done now then go straight to the
offices and and and let's get the
problem solved for the resident but
alongside that if you can feed that in
let's understand and as far as the
actual sort of uh performance around
enforcement action
um we'll get that back we'll get back to
you and other members as well I'm sure
it's something that would interest
everyone
thank you councilmemberton right and
thank you for standing in for Council
Jefferson and thank you for being still
with me Members Merry Christmas
hello thank you members I'm moving on to
item 15 which is the uh notice of motion
update is for information only plant
life
um is now going to go to the 16th of
January
okay that's that particular item and
then the last item apart from urgent
businesses the notice of motion uh this
is for the uh Council procedure rules
again this is going to go to
um oh sorry it's been proposed by yes
it's been proposed and seconded so this
is just going to go to Cabinet
oh sorry I apologize osc and that's it
for that particular item thank you does
somebody else need to Second it I think
oh I'm sorry I apologize sorry cancer
Curtis
thank you sort of councilor Rolf uh do
we need to seek a second an alternative
secondary yeah
thank you very much indeed yes okay sure
just also that in the light of the
questions from Council the Junior from
Council of Bromwich from the comments of
from Council of fochic this motion seems
to be even more relevant to our work
here as a council potential thank you
very much
right members
um item 17 there's no urgent business
therefore I call the meeting to close
and ask if you would like to come to the
back of the room when we're going to put
a few well is it room five
there's we're into room five with some
refreshments for you all and then if you
can come back